on en vient à l'actualité politique avec
donc ce voyage express de nicolas
sarkozy en bulgarie où il a été reçu en
grande pompe deux mois après la
libération des infirmières
une absence remarquée je vous le disais
celle de cécilia sarkozy
d'après le président de la république
elle aurait été blessé par les
polémiques qui ont suivi sa mission à
tripoli l'été dernier alexandre kara
francis forgé autour de nicolas sarkozy
les infirmières et le médecin libre
libre aussi dans leurs émotions tout cas
sachez qu'on vous aime pourtant pleurer
tout cas apporté un cadeau elles n'ont
pas oublié cécilia sarkozy
je suis triste qu'elle ne soit pas là
j'aurais tellement voulu la serrer dans
mes bras avant l'émotion il ya eu les
honneurs le président reçoit la plus
haute distinction bulgare sous les yeux
de sylvie vartan intarissable sur le
couple présidentiel
une longue tragique malheureusement
c'est vrai que jean sarkozy et sa femme
ont joué un rôle prépondérant et ont
accéléré la récupération les aux côtés
du président pas de cécilia sarkozy
explications d'une absence remarquée il
a été blessé
les polémiques qui ont suivi en france
pour bulgari son intervention qui a été
en tout point remarquable d'une certaine
façon décisive
une visite dominée aussi par cette
absence les bulgares n'ont pas caché
leur déception de ne pas voir cécilia
sarkozy devenu ici une véritable héroïne
nationale